- Ski trip!
- You guys have your socks?
Gloves?
Long johns?
- Check, check.
Do you guys have your hats?
- Yeah.
- Yeast infection ointment.
- Che-- (laughter)
- Okay, very funny guys.
- Do you guys have your ski jackets?
Cause we need those.
- Duh!
- Shit, I forgot that at my mom's house.
- Oh, Allie, OK.
Do you think you go can run and grab it and
be back in like a hour so we can
leave and miss traffic?
- Sure.
- Ski trip!
(singing)
- Ski trip.
(calm music)
(knocks)
- Hello.
- Hey, I just wanna grab my ski jacket and leave.
- And to see your mother?
- Uh, the one who remembers Moonlight Sonata
and not her daughter, you talking about the same--
Oh, humor, it's a defense mechanism.
- Who's this, Jess?
I used to have a vest like this once.
- I'm just going to get my jacket.
- C'mon, let's go to the dining room.
Tea time.
(clothes rustling)
(sad music)
- You hate me!
- What reason is there to hate you?
(laughter)
- Told you you hate me.
- A flower in a vase blooms no different
than it does in a plastic cup.
Love is what keeps it alive.
If I'm your water, will you be mine?
- Okay.
(laughter)
(heavy breathing)
- Drink all the way up, okay, swallow.
- I'm really sorry about earlier.
- I didn't know we were having guests, Jess.
Who are you, dear?
Love is what keeps it alive.
- Just someone who loves you very much.
- Isn't that nice?
Yeah, let's finish our tea.
(calm music)